si vous avez des enfants d'âge scolaires
approchez-vous c'est un sujet qui va
beaucoup vous intéresser s'ils sont nés
en juillet en août en septembre il
risque d'avoir un diagnostic de TDAH
plus élevé que ceux qui sont nés en
septembre et décembre c'est ce qu'on
peut lire ce matin dans la presse plus
c'est ce qui ressort d'une étude bon où
on a obtenu copie là au quotidien et on
en fait un article ce matin on va en
discuter avec le docteur guiffallardo
pédiatre à la retraite depuis deux ans
docteur Falardeau bonjour vous avez
aussi écrit tout ce qui bouge n'est pas
t'aider à hache alors vous êtes le vous
êtes le pédiatre idéal pour nous dire ce
que vous pensez quand vous voyez les
grandes lignes de cette étude qui doit
être encore approuvé par les pairs
finaliser il y a un écart on dit je vais
donner les deux chiffres là dans les
plus vieux dans les dans les plus vieux
c'est 15,4% qui ont un TDAH je
diagnostic chez les plus jeunes
c'est presque 5% ça c'est tout un
constat
oui et et ce qui devrait vous vous
surprendre c'est aussi le 15% c'est à
dire que déjà 15.4% c'est un chiffre
exagéré et évidemment 20.8 c'est encore
pire donc oui on savait
je l'avais dit dans mon livre que
probablement que les enfants plus jeunes
étaient plus sur diagnostiqué mais le
surdiagnostic est général et au Québec
ont sur diagnostic tous les enfants mais
encore plus les enfants plus jeunes et
moins mature bon donnez-moi un peu une
base d'explication est-ce que c'est
c'est le diagnostic les règles du
diagnostic qui ne sont pas qui ne sont
plus les bonnes trop souples ou trop
sévère trop de latitude qu'est-ce que
c'est que vous voyez comme problème
en fait c'est que maintenant
à peu près tout le monde connaît les
symptômes du TDAH et
on est en attendant assure diagnostiquer
dans la société c'est à dire tout le
monde dit à mon juste en faire un TDAH
enfin là il est dans l'une sans faire à
l'école donc et les professeurs aussi
ont tendance à sur diagnostiquer et les
parents se retrouvent chez les médecins
et les médecins diagnostiquent beaucoup
trop facilement en fait les médecins
sont pas équipés pour faire des bons
diagnostics un bon diagnostic devrait
être fait par un neuropsychologue c'est
très complexe c'est très coûteux donc on
n'a pas comme on peut pas se permettre
de faire des bons diagnostics on va voir
le médecin le médecin il force des
questionnaires on fait des choses des
fois plus facile un peu plus difficile
mais on pose des diagnostics vraiment
trop facilement au Québec vous même dans
votre carrière vous-même dans votre
derrière vous aviez votre game vous avez
la grille vous aviez votre expérience en
avez-vous
diagnostiquez beaucoup êtes-vous
êtes-vous dans le 20.8 pour 100 ou si
vous étiez plus plus réticent à aller
dans cette voie
moi j'ai travaillé beaucoup en TDAH
c'était un peu ma source spécialité et
j'essayais de faire des bons diagnostics
mais j'étais justement mal pris
c'est-à-dire les gens arrivaient au
bureau avec des questionnaires remplis à
l'école et
les parents n'avaient pas les moyens de
payer deux trois mille dollars pour
aller faire évaluer leur enfant donc je
devais vivre justement avec ça et c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que j'écris lise
parce que j'ai réalisé que c'était
étouffant c'est qu'on me demandait des
diagnostics
j'ai fait des mauvais diagnostics
moi-même j'ai réalisé un moment donné
que je m'étais trompé dans certains
diagnostics c'est pas facile de faire ce
diagnostic là et surtout ce que j'ai
réalisé c'est que la plupart des faux
diagnostic c'était des enfants an ou des
enfants qui avaient d'autres
problématiques comme les enfants qui
avaient des des enfants autistes par
exemple ah ouais c'est pas du tout du
tout la même chose mais dites moi ce
matin brièvement là s'il y a des parents
ou des grands-parents qui vous écoutent
et qui ont des enfants qui ont eu un
diagnostic comme ça est-ce que est-ce
qu'ils doivent qu'est-ce que vous leur
conseiller de faire par exemple ce matin
en voyant ça s'ils sont inquiets par les
résultats préliminaires moi je dirais si
on diagnostic qui prennent une petite
dose de médicaments et qui vont bien ça
va si un diagnostic et qu'on est
tendance à augmenter augmenter augmenter
les doses de médicaments c'est ce qui
arrive souvent chez les faux diagnostics
c'est qu'on sur médicaments encore plus
là qui se méfie et qui pose des
questions c'est sûr que c'est pas facile
en fait les pédiatres au Québec en 2020
on avait demandé une commission
parlementaire on l'a obtenu il y a eu
des recommandations faites par cette
commission parlementaire là mais on
attend encore bon
accuser la pandémie mais là la pandémie
ça fait quand même longtemps et il
faudrait que le ministre mettre en place
les recommandations de commission
parlementaire on va suivre ça puis je
vous remercie beaucoup d'avoir l'hôpital
de parler ce matin j'espère que ça a été
utile à bien des gens bien des enfants
tiens aussi qui pourraient bénéficier
d'une tête un ajustement comme ça alors
docteur Falardeau merci à la prochaine à
la prochaine au revoir merci pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI